my mother used to always tell me that
regardless of how much you might despise
someone once you get to know them you'll
always find something about them that
you like and I found that a very good
observation and the same thing applied
to follow the Reverend Falwell spoke out
against me for 15 years on his old time
gospel hour and then we did a satire on
him in the magazine which was rather
unflattering and he didn't like that so
he sue ma'am we fought for another four
years in court and it became a landmark
Supreme Court decision we were better
enemies then I had an opportunity to
meet with him well the trials were all
over and I figured you know why not I
think he was misguided I think he was
wrong about many things and there was
really nothing that I agreed with him
about some of the things we just so
bizarre and so far out like he held a
press conference one day to say that the
Teletubbies were gay because there were
purple clothes or something I called him
up and I said relevant I think you one
of the best-known evangelists in the
world and I said how could you do
something so stupid this can't help you
he said you know Worley and I went to
him about that I was wrong I shouldn't
have done that
that's how follow was it wasn't that
human necessarily mean spirited but he
said and did a lot of things that came
off that way
you